heroes mentor-mentee no heroes hero the
best story for me I think when I was
young doing a hundred dragon fighting
with Bruce Lee and I was behind the
camera ho waiting waiting I just see
booze then I just ran after Delia pompa
satiny my eyes blind because he's just
one stick right on my hair haha he
missed it but I just I do nothing I just
and I just fell you know little dizzy
but it's okay I look at it boosts Lee
Bruce Lee doesn't do anything you look
at everybody and keep acting turn around
back until the director say cut then he
just saw the two stick just turn around
oh my god he run to me and lift me up
I'm sorry I'm sorry
and actually I'm not paying anymore
because no young guy on me very tough
but it certainly I don't know why I just
pretend very painful oh I just want
Billy home him along as long as his can
I said Oh doing a whole day every time
you look at me like this I said okay and
I think that's the best moment then
somehow he'll run to me
what's your name as in my name Jackie
what style we're learning as a southern
style okay then talk to me
Jackie huh Jackie Jackie okay
of course I'm familiar with Muhammad Ali
you don't just have him here he is
global he is he is the man Muhammad Ali
was a guy that doing what had not been
done before changed the face not only
the face of his game but the face of the
world you know he was a he was outspoken
he fought he fought for what he believed
in and done he was charismatic he he he
was a legend a hero and I looked up to
him one of my first heroes was Muhammad
Ali
when I was eleven years old there was a
group of people and they tried to attack
me and a fight broke out
and it was just me and one guy before
before everyone else jumped in on me but
we were fighting each other and I
slipped a punch and ice and I shook off
my shoulders and said Muhammad Ali and
true a shot and he rolled under the shop
I fell into a knee and I ended up on top
of him so I'm at this column I said
Muhammad Ali and I'm punching him in the
head and then somebody came in and tried
to kick me and then a whole group of
them came in and it was just a big fight
but it was me against six of them and I
ended up getting my ass whupped but that
first guy you you whip them out I sure I
don't know Ali shuffle I'm only 11 years
old I don't the Ali shuffle threw a left
hook he rolled onto the left hook with
you if it was good of him to roll he
started coming and rolled under it but
he rolled right into a knee yeah I was I
was I was prepared
I was I was studying tape ya know so
definitely Muhammad Ali was a hero of
mine I used Stevie Wonder as an
inspiration hmm I look up to a great
deal just for the way that he crafted
music and his his connection to the
spirit and boy back then I I used him as
a role model and trying to play all the
instruments and be very self contained
and keep my vision clear so word spread
very quickly about what I could do a lot
of people knew about it you you truly
adore your parents don't you I love my
parents just so much mate I you know
like my mom how'd you be you know I was
born on her birthday and and all she
ever did was just love me and prop me up
and get me back out in there and my dad
just the legend of the universe when I
was the tiniest little kid Android look
up at my dad and you know he was like
larger than life he was just like this
action hero he was everything I wanted
to be and all I've done in my life is
following his footsteps Minnie Kim and
try to be him and nowadays I just try to
make him proud night yeah I love my
parents like
nothing else it's just they are
everything to me absolutely everything
in the day that my mum the went was the
dial awesome al awesome lost something
really big
you got to see everyone as a mentor
though your whole crowd somebody who
works for you might be imagine I
remember when when I became CEO I was
not a great financial wizard I never did
become a financial wizard but I at least
I had this fella who worked for me ten
years my junior 34 3 3 3 years old Wow
who I made CFO he basically dumped his
brain into mine I live with him and as
we went through all of us that left side
right side and sudden the balance sheet
from A to Z and and he was an enormously
valuable person I've had people who I'm
on my board who were completely
committed to our success who would
challenge every people appointment I
would make who would FA is sure hey
right I think the business media is a
great mentor he may laugh at that but I
think fortune business week there's a
business language I find them mentors
read every story I can't understand
myself somebody can be in business and
not read all those stories I think you
learn you learn what strategies didn't
work didn't work some of the stories
aren't quite accurate some of the line
through so what you're closely learning
the rhythm of business so education and
teaching is all around you it as far as
today's real is we have an enormous tag
cadre people today are just better than
they were before it's more competitive
it's no longer when you become CEO today
it's no longer the coronation it's the
beginning of a new competitive career I
remember one night in 1980 when I became
CEO I would go to these meetings where
people would sit around it and that
briefing books prepared by huge staffs
and their pontificate about the economy
and the other nonsense them and nothing
is mouthing words it was
now today people in shirtsleeves getting
in there and doing it because the global
competition is so tough you never make
it by yourself you always need others to
help you I'm good at what I do I'm
really really good at M&A and I'm not
saying this with any level of arrogance
the only reason why I'm saying that is
I've put in over 25 years perfecting the
craft but the reason one of the reasons
why I'm good is that a partner out of
the Dallas office took me under his wing
and he said let me apprentice you let me
show you how to become good at it he
didn't say it in exactly those words but
in retrospect that's what happened to me
so mentorship is incredibly important
was Muhammad Ali a hero reviews well
naturally far as Bobson is concerned and
what he has done he was my hero just
like rope in here this is my hero what
did you say to him when he told you he
loved you
well I was paralyzed because he made my
day
so what leaders what leaders of the 20th
century do you admire well I have
answered that question is not the
question of a leader it's a question of
a human being or does something to make
an ordinary individual to feel I am a
human being and I have a future and I
can go to bed feeling strong and full of
hope you know I had heroes and I
obviously people influenced me you know
my my dad drove me to tell my surf
contest my mom you know she she always
kept me in my place you know it always
kept me grounded and you know she always
told me if I ever got a big head she
would she would beat my ass
smack me in do whatever she threatened
me a little bit but it was all for the
right reasons and sort of just you know
kept me on a straight and narrow path
really but you know well we all have our
heroes and people we look up to and
surfing I had a lot of those people I
didn't know when one hero I've always
had who no longer lives has been John
Kennedy oh yeah of course I was very
much in the US at that time that person
stands out still as very much money my
hero at that time and continues to get
me emotionally nostalgic about the days
I sure that I was there when I got the
Nobel Prize I was asked to write an
autobiography
our life and our intellectual
development and in writing that I
remembered vividly the profound impact
that my high school physics teacher mr.
miner played in my intellectual
development in the 12th grade it was the
final exam I kind of flubbed the
question and then he read written in the
margin I'm disappointed he wasn't trying
to teach his facts he was actually
trying to teach us a learning process
learning whether you understand
something or not was probably the most
important thing I began to learn in his
class that lesson I took with me not
only through college and graduate school
but for my entire career as a physicist
for me growing up my parents were my
greatest mentors and heroes and they
taught me how to be you know a decent
human being not so much about business
it didn't have a lot of business
background but just how to treat people
how to believe in myself believe comes
from them and then my first real kind of
business mentor was Bill Gates even
though I'd never met him and he helped
save my company when I realized that I
didn't have to come up with every idea
myself that somebody has already solved
the problems that I'm trying to
accomplish and I just applied his
lessons from how he started Microsoft to
my software company at the time when I
was 19 and just sucking as an
entrepreneur and making every mistake
that I could and not getting results and
I was able to go from wanting to quit
the business to being acquired in three
years thanks to the strategies from Bill
Gates and now I see every successful
person as a mentor in different ways I
made the top ten Series in the ancestor
series for myself because I want to
every day be surrounded by these people
who are accomplishing great things in
their lives and the more that I can be
around these people the more a little
bit more of their magic secret sauce
kind of rubs off onto me the way that
they think and their mindset rubs off on
to me and if you just hear message once
it doesn't often stink in like you may
acknowledge it but then you go back to
your habits and your old patterns and
the way you used to do things but if you
consistently hear the same message over
and over and over again from different
people in their own
ways from you know actors and athletes
and entrepreneurs and inventors and
politicians and they're all saying the
same kind of thing it slowly starts to
shift your mindset at least it does for
me and so that's why I try to surround
myself with those great lessons on a
daily basis and the people who think
that you can't learn from a Kanye West
or a Donald Trump or Hillary Clinton you
know the depend on what side of the
political spectrum you're on you can
learn from everybody who's had success
you may not want to be like I don't want
to be the next Kanye West I want to be
the first Evan Carmichael but I can
learn something from Kanye from chump
from Hillary that I can apply to make me
the best version of myself and so if you
create that environment where you're
constantly surrounding yourself with
those aspirational mentors with wisdom
from people who've done a lot more than
you slowly over time you'll set to break
through those limiting barriers there's
personal beliefs that are holding you
where you are and you start to build a
life that is great and exciting and when
you look forward to I wonder has a major
impact so thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed this video
I'd love to know your take I'd love to
know how you are finding mentors and who
some of your heroes are leave it in the
comments below I'm gonna join the
discussion thank you again for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon